[Musique]
depuis les années 60 le port de montréal
est l'un des points d'entrée les plus
importants au monde
pour la cocaïne et l'héroïne la mafia
contrôle et le gros du trafic mais il
fallait sans arrêt se battre contre les
bikers et tous les gangs qui voulaient
leur part du gâteau
tout ça a pris fin sous le règne du
parrain vito et où on se fait la guerre
les uns aux autres reste à savoir si
vous vous disputez les bailleurs coin de
rue où notre part du gâteau on bosse
ensemble c'est ça qui a lancé la plus
belle opération de tous les temps je
sais quel point mon père est appréciée
mais tu n'es pas de la famille declan
risque sa peau c'est moi ton fils nous
sommes venus vous arrêter pourquoi 1980
ça vous évoque quoi il peut me faire
confiance
autant que toi et il le sait un homme
est arrivé de calabre pour tuer vite il
nous tombe dessus de tous les côtés
montrent leur qui commandent faut que tu
prennes soin de mon fils est pas le chef
de famille il sait tous que ton père
c'est pas toi tu sais à quel point tu as
mérité sur ce coup là
ce sont des groupes mafieux qui contrôle
tout le système double s'incruster
depuis des années ils ont tenté de
liquider la venue d'auch toi tu penses
quoi toi la diplomatie a fait son temps
à
ils ont tué mon fils chaque mètre ont
tué était le fils de quelqu'un
le comportement que tu as pourrait
provoquer la mort de beaucoup de mende
n'importe qui peut agiter à flins mais
les gens dignes de confiance à court pas
les rues
notre credo c'est de prendre soin de nos
amis tant qu'ils ont à coeur de se
comporter en ami